FANS WANT TO SEE A
THAT IS WHAT HE HAD BEEN
PLAYING.
HE GOT HURT.
HE IS RING THE
PUCK INTO THE WE
CAN.
FOR SURE THE NATIVE LIKE TOTHIS
MORNING.
DEALING WITH A BIT OF
ILLNESS.>> THE FACE-OFF TO TED
THAT DEVILS
NETS.
HE THE LEFT AFTER THAT TRY.
HE WILL TRICK
IN WHAT A LOOK.
THE PUCK STAYS IN THE
EXCELLENT EFFORT.
150 FEET DOWN THE ICE.
>>>>THE GAME.
COACHES AND BROADCASTERS.
1-0 CAROLINA
KICKS OUT.
CAROLINA BACK THE
GOOD STICK.
PLAYED AWAY.
OUT TO CENTER ICE.
HE DOWN THE ICE.
WASH NEW
>> GETTING READY TO START THE P
HE PULLS UP.
STILL HAS FLEX OFF.
TO THE LOOSE PUCK.
OUT
A BULLET THAT WAS THE
STARTING GOALTENDER.>> HE IS PU
HE SENDS THE E IS NO FINE HOLD
THERE.
HE DENIES HIM TO KEEP THIS A
ONE GOAL THE ICE.
NOW SENT BACK UP THE PUCK INTO
THE  ANY
GIVEN MO A LOOK AT
THE OPEN ICE AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT ALMOSTHIM.
THAT IS DEFLECTED.